こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
あの、ぼく、今テスト期間なんで、
マジで今、ちょっと今勉強しなきゃいけなんですけども
生意気な、後輩YouTuberがおりまして
SITという男がいるんですよ。
あぁー、動画は見なくて
いいですよ！
なんか、そいつがね、今日ね
こいつはね、
飛んだ野郎だよ
マジ、生意気なんですよ
ちょっと、見てわかるとおり
これですよ、いきなり、この態度っすよ
この俺様に向かって
この俺様に向かってですよ
『はじめーん！！！明日静岡いますか！？』
『いる！』　『夜くらいからいけますか？』
いや、テスト勉強だって、！
、という話をして
『わかりました！　がんばってください』
と、来るわけじゃないっすか
それからの『映画いこ～。。。』って
なめてんのか（怒）
で、そっから、今日になって、
いきなり、まず、電話ですからね、
まぁ、な、こいつ、高校生なんだよ
で、いきなり電話出ろと、
で、なに事、って、
びっくりしたんっす、テスト勉強って言ってたから
で、『テスト勉強しなきゃ！』、と
『実は、新年の挨拶をしにきました。』
おせーよ（怒）
でも、前から言ってたんっす、今日は無理と
昼ごはん食べましょ、みたいな感じで
それに今日は、無理っていってたからさ～
っていう話をしてて、
でっなんか、この写真が、
僕ん家の近くまで、もう、来てるんっすよ
怖いんっすよ！
で、なんか、『ドッキリしようと思った』とか言ってきて、
『ごめんなさい』って
という、流れでございます。
どう思いますか？
処するしかないよな（怒）
この、テスト期間の、この俺様の家に
突撃する、後輩YouTuberだよ
倒す。
YouTuberのほんとの怖さを、教えてあげようと思います。
あっ、OK、OK、じゃ、ちょっと、もうちょい待ってて
はーい
では、早速、仕掛けの準備をしていきましょう。
まずは、こちら
たいりょ、あぁー
大量のビー玉です。
ちょっと追加します。
で、この、大量のビー玉の中に
こちら、大量のスーパーボールを入れます。
わぁ、凄いなこれは、
階段から上って来るんっすよ
で、階段から上って来るところを、
めがけて、これを、ぶっかけてやろうと思います
ビー玉は、この、チクチク痛いんっすよ
ビー玉は、チクチク痛いし、スーパーボールは跳ねる
「上からの恐怖」と「打撃の恐怖」っていう
2段恐怖の、組み合わせで攻撃が来るんで
だいぶ、怖いと思います
ケガ...ケガケガケガしない程度のぉ～
怪我しない程度のぉ～スピードで
ぶつけてやろうと思います（嘘）
では、行こう
はい、とりあえず、今から来るんですけども
階段、この階段から、あいつが来るので、
ここから、落としてやろうと思います。
で、ちょっと、落とす時用に
できたぞ、
こういう感じで、ここから、さぁ～っと行って
ま、さーっといってほしいと思います
OK!
では、呼びましょう！
もしもし、・・・・・OK
SHITTOぉ！！
（SIT）あぁ～気もちぃ～☆
おめ、生意気だな、オメェ
ふふ、でかくない？何か、がたい
なぜ、こんなことされたかわかるか？
（SIT）そりゃ、もうサブチャンネルでも、あげたとおり
（SIT）ポルトガル語のテストがあるのに・・・
俺は、言ったぞ、LINEで言ったぞ、ちゃんと
SITチャンネルの紹介だ
いや、もう、どんなチャンネルか言えば、
みんな、登録してくれるかもしんない
（SIT）どんなチャンネルか？
そう、自分の宣伝をしよう！ここで
登録者増えるぞ！
いくんだ！